these painters that try and do a job
four of them take 12 days almost two
weeks to do it so what we're asking now
is how many days will it take if I
increase the number of painters if I had
six painters instead of four okay
can I turn this off now cuz I'm going to
need the rest of the board yeah okay now
this is actually really important what
I'm gonna ask you do is rule off where
you've done the rest of the quick
questions
wake up here we go we're all off what
you've done that and we're going to
think about this question four together
right so we said for painters gave you
12 days and now the question is how long
for six pages okay now a few of you put
your hands up and you said you had an
answer anyone want to volunteer your
answer yeah go ahead
eight days eight days question mark now
I saw a few of you who gave I saw a few
if you had that number on your page and
I asked several of you the same question
which was how confident are you that
that answer is right and some of you
kind of like I'm kind of confident now
that you're like I just guessed it
seemed like it was in the rough ballpark
okay now what we're going to be covering
today the idea we're covering today and
the graphs are going to be looking at
are exactly about these problems so I
was trying to be a little bit sneaky and
introduce you to this topic before
introduced it to you here's the idea
right let's just imagine that you know
you're one of the four pages and your
three friends sorry guys
they just digit you okay so now there's
just one page on the job so let's just
assume you all work at the same pace if
there's four times
fewer painters then how much longer is
the whole task going to take four times
fewer less people doing the work so fear
what do you think you
okay 48 days yes Sophie said now this
makes sense to me right because like oh
you're gonna work four times slower
aren't you
now four times slower because there's
only one of you so therefore it would
take four times longer you following
with me so four times slower four times
longer and this idea here we actually
call these work days right so there are
going to be 48 work days and the more
workers you throw at it the faster it
will get make sense so for example let's
just do a simple one if I had two pages
only half the group left okay how fast
or how long is it going to take yeah 24
days and you can see this from two
different angles number one if you go
from just you you double the number of
workers you'll work twice as fast
weren't you so that's why it takes half
the time yeah or if you go back to the
original situation it's like half of us
left so it's gonna take us twice as long
twelve days okay
now you can probably see there's a
relationship between all of these
numbers right 148 to 24 for lots of 12
can you see what's the connection that
brings us to six and eight what's the
thing that combines them yep salient it
has what harves exactly 48 to 24 to 12
though 12 doesn't have to a does it let
me maybe ask one more what if you have
three painters hmm three painters how
could we work this out have a think I
think your brain is getting everyone
want us all to get there right can we go
back to the original situation of
everyone's left you you're there working
by yourself
so unfortunately to take you that that's
a really long time that's really sad for
painting your house okay 48 days but now
you can work three times faster as a
group three times faster than that so
what would three times faster than 48 a
bit
what's that third of 48 it's 16 right
okay now in order since the pattern here
right hopefully you can see that there's
division happening and multiplication
you know I said to you all what's 48
divided by 3 that's how you gave me
ha right so what's really going on the
pattern between all of these and it also
matches the answer that we've got is
that 1 times 48 is 48 2 times 24 is also
48 3 times 16 in the original question
there's 4 times 12 and this is why we
can no not just say I think I'm on the
right ball Pororo I can know that 6
times 8 actually does match my pattern
does this make sense so we can actually
formulate this in a rule and I'd love
you to make like a little subheading for
me we call this idea here's the heading
for you in direct variation in direct
variation hopefully this is ringing a
little bit of a bell the idea here right
this example was painters the number of
painters times the amount of time that
you spent in our example it always equal
to what happened when I multiply through
you always got the same number which was
48 okay like so so mathematicians
famously lazy we don't wanna write
painters and time every single time so
I'm just going to write P and T equals
48
okay now this here is an indirect
variation relationship when you got two
things they're connected together they
always multiply to give the same thing
right now the important thing here is
did you notice as the number of painters
increases as the number of painters
increases what happens to the time it
takes it goes down it decreases right
now do you remember do remember the
phrase direct variation direct variation
so this is simpler right in direct
variation the more you have of one thing
the more you have of the other right
does this make sense so for example
sorry this is really cheesy but I'm
doing it just so that you have a thing
in front of you remember right if you
had $3 you in academics you could buy
exactly one book they go if you had more
money if you got $60 you can buy
surprise surprise two books you can see
I'm not very delicate with these that's
what
happens when you're north okay you don't
care about your moves ninety dollars
three books okay
you getting on fondant yeah I do have
one more there we go cash go one two
three four hundred twenty dollars how
many looks okay more money more money
more books does this make sense that's
direct variation but indirect variation
this is why it has its own name right it
has this kind of reversed relationship
you increase one thing you decrease the
other okay that's the key thing about it
in fact I love you to maybe write that
with me and maybe if you got some colors
there to indicate this so I like to put
one arrow up and one arrow down okay as
one quantity increases what happens the
other one again the other quantity
decreases right so this is sort of
opposite thing happening right I'm going
to really highlight it with color so I'm
putting my increase in red and then
decrease in blue okay now what does this
actually look like well see this guy
here P T equals 48 we can actually draw
and show this relationship visually so
underneath you've got here if you've got
a ruler who's got a ruler there if you
have a ruler be really handy I'm sorry
I'd lend you one but the only one I have
is this comically large one which you
probably don't wanna use on your book so
maybe borrow a ruler from a friend and
underneath this we're going to draw a
set of axes together
Thank You mr. chairman this set of
actions we're going to draw we don't
need to have the whole Cartesian plane
we're just going to do a quarter of it
actually and we normally label the
Cartesian plane what do we normally be
able to be horizontal axis we normally
call it X and we normally call the other
one wine right but this time I'm not
actually interested in X&Y I'm
interested for this particular in
painters and time painters in time so
I'm going to make this horizontal axis
the painter axis and all painters rather
and the vertical one I'm going to Claude
time okay now just look up for a minute
and it's okay if you're still drawing
but I just want you to see me doing this
part okay
I'm not gonna worry about us being to
visually accurate here I just wanna get
the overall sense as you can see I
increase the number of painters right
the amount of time that it takes reduces
right so I'm gonna get a shape and this
is the one I'd love you to draw right
I'm gonna create a shape that looks
roughly like this okay so you can go
ahead you can go it draw that sort of
it's like an arc of a circle sort of now
you could pick points on there you could
say oh this point here might be like
having a single painter like all that
friends do just so that's why the time
is so high at one painter 48 days and
then as it sort of curves down the more
painters you add the lower the time goes
okay but importantly let's think about
this suppose we all started painting
we're going to everyone enjoy every
technology high school to stop a tree or
2,000 painters okay what might the time
be I think we do go all the gray to be
much shorter be very small what the time
be zero no would it still take us like
you know a second to do like a little
dab of paint and the person Nick sauce
they're still taking some time right
what if we had like everyone in Sydney
that's like four and a half million
people wouldn't the time ever get to
zero no it might be really short but it
never quite seen the time axis right it
never quite gets to zero now we can draw
this visually there's a dotted line
we're gonna put on and has a name is
they don't remember what we call it
you've got that kind of shape down here
like that starts with an A now this way
before yeah it's an asymptote very
good see I'd love you to label with this
with me it's a weird word hard to spell
asy MP t OTE so there's an asymptote
there right no matter how many painters
you throw at this right peak and
painters can go to like millions and
millions and millions but you'll never
get to time equals zero okay because um
they're still going to take a second or
two or something like that
okay now that approaching right we call
that an assets hope is overall shape
this arc that we've drawn it also has a
name it starts with an H has anyone
heard this name before we call this guy
a hyperbola right same kind of a part in
the word as a parabola in Latin bola
just means the wound like it's the arc
that something makes when you throw it
okay but it does look different to a
parabola however it's got that same
curvature it's not a straight line which
is very important direct variation
straight line in direct variation you've
got this thing happening okay